- I'm getting such a
feeling of like ugh from it.
Like it's the last place
I wanna be right now.
(creepy playful music)
- So when I was about,
I'd say seven years old
I went to a birthday party
and they had a bouncy house.
And I'm bouncing around,
having a good time like you do
when you're a kid in a bouncy house.
And then at some point I was in a corner
and then I fell and then
someone near me fell
and the added weight started to weigh down
the corner of the bouncy house.
And I remember feeling some,
this weight on my body.
- I was about 10 years old and
we were having a family party
so my mom thought it would be fun
if she rented a bouncy house.
So we decided that we
were gonna have some fun
in the bouncy house
before anyone got there.
My dad was leaf-blowing
so he had headphones on
to block the sound from the leaf blower.
He accidentally unplugged the bouncy house
while my mom and my
brothers were inside of it
and then all of a sudden it
rapidly started deflating.
And so my mom took charge
and saved all of our lives.
- I was probably four years old.
Big birthday party for
a classmate of mine.
I'm sort of off in the
corner, so I kind of
bounce my way over, there's a kid
with one of the balls from the ball pit.
He's using the ball to wipe his ass.
And so, really ever since then
I've been a little bit traumatized.
- And I distinctly remember feeling like
"Oh my God, life is real and
there is pain in the world
"and I'm experiencing it right now."
Like genuine terror and fear.
- So ever since then I have been
quite fearful of bouncy houses.
- I mean, I just think that kids
do disgusting things in these things.
(funky upbeat music)
- No, I'm not going into a bounce house.
- (laughing) No.
- You know, I'm sure I could handle it.
Why, do you guys have a bounce house?
- You do?
- There's a bouncy house here?
Oh my God.
- Oh no.
- I can hear it.
- I'm actually gonna bounce
in a bouncy house today.
- Hello, old friend.
- Oh my God!
How did I not know this
was gonna be a thing?
- I'm getting such a
feeling of like ugh from it.
Like it's the last place
I wanna be right now.
- You think I could make it through there?
(laughter)
- It's not that I dislike bounce houses
I'm realizing that I think
I might be afraid of them.
- You know, it's not that upsetting.
It's very, it's bouncy but you know
my head's right here, I got a giant head.
(suspenseful music)
- Alright.
- You can put this in black
and white, dramatic recreation.
I fell and then the next
kid fell on me and then
they all piled on and I
was crushed in such a way.
- This is a blast, I feel like
I'm reliving my childhood.
- No, no I don't like it.
(laughing)
- Ooh yeah, you see that?
- Maybe it has nothing
to do with the incident.
Maybe I just deep down hate bounce houses.
I now have two traumatic
bounce house stories.
- You know, I'm not afraid, I acknowledge
that what happened was an
accident when I was a kid
and I'm not, you know, there's
nothing to be afraid of.
(laughs) Good bit.
- (laughing) Oh my God!
You guys, I can't believe you did this.
This is epic, props, props.
(groovy music)